donc comment ça se passe de tomber
amoureuse de lui il écoutait hewitt au
collège et au collège avec vous
il est incroyable et un foyer connu
encore une vacance d'accord très bien
vous êtes connu aucune vacance donc au
début ça se passe très bien c'est votre
petit amoureux on va dire vous avez 14
ans
il est gentil avec al ajmi indice est
d'accord donc et voilà il avait 17 ans
vous avez 14 ans et au départ vous êtes
il ya gentil attentionné c'est ça tout
va bien et vous bout de combien de temps
il commence à vous demander
de faire des choses un peu curieuse j'ai
envie de dire un peu moins d'un an après
un peu moins d'un an après dont vous
êtes un pendant un an avec lui au moins
d'un an après il vous dit quoi en fait
en fait c'est pas venu lui c'est venu d
amiens d'accord
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais il
faisait déjà bossé des filles et je les
avais sur les raisons mois et après ils
m'ont envoyé des messages et m'ont
proposé tout ça
c'est parti de là mais comment ça se
passe il vous propose en fait c'est
votre cv les amis de votre votre
amoureux qui vous propose de vous
prostituées
de sa part à lui monsieur qui demande
d'accord il vous dit quoi pour pour
voilà pour faire comprendre que c'est de
la prostitution
ce que c'est votre amoureux à la base et
il vous dit un jour
il a quoi comme argument
fait ils sont en fuite ou les deux du
coup la fût que ça coûte de l'argent
ouais donc c'est plutôt ça va lui s'est
présenté comme un petit revenu spontanée
ponctuelles pour payer l'hôtel payer à
manger donkey donc ils lui disent pour
qu'on s'en sorte au dessus de
prostituées oui puis en même temps ils
amènent aussi sur le sur le sujet que si
c'est lui qui fait quelque chose
d'illicite et est ce que la prison et
comme il a déjà commencer à la mettre un
peu sous emprise et l'isoler ci lui va
en prison qui sera là pour elle donc
c'est comme ça que commence côté un peu
machiavélique de l'emprise puis d'un ou
deux clients pour dépanner donc quand il
ya une dizaine de jours qu'on vient de
faire parce que au départ donc ils sont
en fuite qu'est ce qui se passe que vous
entendiez bien avec assia tout se
passait bien oui alors les cas ça se
passait bien sauf que moi j'étais en
train d'effectuer une peine d'un an de
corps une vieille condamnation de 2013
d'accord jeune équipe du coup j'étais
pas là et je me rends compte que son
téléphone ne marche plus sa carte sim
n'est plus active donc le plus ma
cellule je me connecte à sa boîte mail
gmail et je trouve une annonce de one
ans ce site d'escorting révisé qui nous
découvrent en prison que votre fille
se prostituent alors il va complètement
la coupe et sa famille ne tous
complètement voilà il est sous emprise
totale total a par son petit frère à qui
la laisse parler de temps en temps mais
toujours sur haut parleur toujours son
petit frère l'a 10 ans maintenant à quoi
donc à l'époque de la vallée aux
militants c'est ça et est donc
elle est complètement dépendante de lui
enfin il a tout fait pour qu'elle soit
sous dépendance alors on est
complètement un jour il va il va lui
proposer des plans donc pour payer comme
vous dites l'hôtel et les courses du
moment où il y en a parlé parce que
acier ou
comment ils vous adhap services est venu
la première fois que ça toi qu'il fasse
quelque chose n'est pas lui
c'était spontané en même temps avec
l'argent qu'elle gagnait sur les passes
par exemple il s'est permis lui offrir
les bagues de fiançailles et de lui
mettre la bague au doigt avec ce qu'elle
avait gagné avec ses fesses quoi donc il
aller loin dans dans son
dans ses propos il était capable d'être
jaloux de ne pas la laisser avoir son
téléphone de faire le mec possessif tout
en la laissant faire dix clients par
jour
la première fois comment commencer à ça
arrive la première fois
ça elle me l'a même à moi me lapp encore
raconté ouais c'est ça ouais c'est trop
compliqué la première
m'a parlé de d'autrefois mais pas de
celle en tout cas et c'était des amis a
dit toujours des amis à lui des
connaissances ont bien dit annonçant les
noms ça pouvait être excusez moi du
terme mais les vieux gros dégueulasse de
65 watts et oui mais pédophiles quoi
aller 15 ans et un bébé demandé
ça pouvait être de toute origine de tout
âge et de tout milieu social a parlé
tout à l'heure de 10 passes par jour
15 ont
cessé
ils viennent d'où ces gens comment
comment ils sont comment comment irna
comment il est maintenant mais c'est pas
ça mais comment ils jouent comme ils
sont au courant que cette jeune fille la
baisse annoncée en fait moi quand pour
retrouver un siège me suis fait passer
pour un client donc j'ai créé un conte
masculin et fait rentrer en contact avec
elle plusieurs fois de cette manière
en fait c'est un panneau panel complet
de deux jeunes filles c'est vous mettez
les critères la localisation l'âge
l'origine ethnique est un peu comme un
marché quoi mais sur un site d'escorting
donc ils savent qu'elles sont mineures
au csa l'hébergeur du site franchement
là aujourd'hui elle a 17 ans mais quand
elle avait 15 ans et qu'elle a des
clients qui sont venus dans la chambre
alors qu'il l'avait frappée qu'elle
n'avait pas d'hygiène qui lui donnait
pas de produits pour se laver qui la
laissait pas changé qu'elle était à une
serpillière excusez moi mais ça se
voyait qu'elle avait 15 ans et qu'elle
était maltraitée elle était pour moi
c'est de la traite d'êtres humains et ça
les empêche pas dû passer par dessus
quand même c'est dégueulasse combien
ça pouvait représenter combien d'argent
par jour pour pour son son proxénète
ancien petit ami devenu proxénète bien
sans même parcours
mais les permis leur parle
et cet argent donc il aller pour ils ont
fait quoi il le gardait pour lui donc
qui paient la chambre d'hôtel il se
payer à manger et une fois qu'ils
avaient mangé à pouvez manger ces restes
mais jamais elles avaient le choix du
repas
assiette et essayer de sortir de cette
situation tout seul ou pas du tout qui
était vraiment tu t'es dit c
c'est ma vie je pourrais pas en sortir
étaient résignés les niches je pourrais
rien faire
t'as jamais essayé de lui parler
non aussi
piégé qu'elle les micros dans les champs
c'est oui dionis à l'arrivée qu'elle
essaye de parler avec lui en fait c'est
parce qu'on a déjà parlé tous les deux
et elle essayait de lui demander
pourquoi exerça où il disait vouloir
changer dès qu'elle essaie d'entrer en
contact avec lui verbalement dans une
chambre d'hôtel ou quoi il rentrait pas
sur le sujet parce que pour lui avouer
le piéger elle avait posé des micros
elle voulait le faire incarcérer il
était très petit kotick un peu le
paradoxe mais qu'en fait sur savait ce
qu'il faisait au final peut-être tu
avais peur assure en fait c'est sa
taille peur de quoi de le perdre ou tu
avais peur pour kiki qui pourquoi pas
santé pour ta santé physique
taillé pour qui
les deux nés 2 metal est pas aussi qu'il
peut le perdre
était amoureuse de lui ça sent pris
toujours même après tout ça
je pense que j'étais pas amoureuse
j'étais comme accro mais s'était pas
fait utiliser que tu pouvais pas vivre
sans lui tu avais mis sous une cloche en
fait sous dépendance c'est ce qu'on
disait depuis de taden jamais connu
voilà c'est ça tu t'es dit si je le
perds je me retrouve tout seul chez rien
c'est ça en fait qui a fait que
tu arrivais pas t'en sortir
oui nicolas mais je suis désolé parce
que c'est quand même un témoignage et
bravo à notre l'armée etc et qu'est ce
qui se passe dans votre tête à quoi peut
penser comment vous pouvez vous en
sortir quelques qu'est ce qui se passe à
ce moment là quand on est sous une telle
emprise pardon de vous poser la question
mais je pense que l'actuel me dis mille
dix mille jeunes a vraisemblablement
aujourd'hui qui elle même comment on
vous dit même à 15000 donc là le beau
témoignage est extraordinaire pour ces
jeunes qui veulent s'en sortir qui ont
peut-être pas forcément accès à la télé
mais mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans
votre tête à quel moment vous et vous
croyez encore un avenir comment ça se
fasse au kek
alors ça la solution que j'avais vu
c'était de faire semblant qui est un
client et lui il partait dans la salle
de bain se cacher moi j'ouvre la porte
et au lieu de faire rentrer le clan
short et m'ont
envoyé à chaque point c'est quand même
bon revenir à chaque fois
ça vous n'aviez pas la force de partir
définitivement vous saviez pas où aller
vous saviez vous que j'étais en fugue
quand on met en fuite deux plus petits
jours on est viré du foyer où en est on
a plus de place dans soyez là donc si je
partais j'avais nulle part où aller les
verts rien pas d'argent
alors vous avez dit vous avez appris en
connectant sur un site que la situation
de votre fille vous doutiez de quelque
chose ou pas du tout non du tout non
quelle est votre réaction quand vous
voyez ça vous dit qu'est ce que vous
êtes en prison ou plus vous dit pas elle
vous dit quoi vous dit qu'est ce que tu
veux faire quoi je vais sp1 franchement
c'est le dégoût la honte tout ce qui me
dégoûte le plus comment je vais pouvoir
la regarder à ce qu'un jour je vais
pouvoir la roux touché est ce qu'elle
est toujours ma fille franchement c'est
un sentiment trop je suis pas consciente
de l'emprise je suis consciente d'avoir
lu les messages qu'elle échange avec les
clients comment ma fille à moi elle peut
ne pas se respecter c'est ça dans ma
tête en fait c'est c'est compliqué mais
si c'était vous qui écrivez le message
vous c'était non c'était lui c'est un
message à elle en fait j'ai lu les
conversations en connectant son à son
compte les conversations qu'elle avait
avec des clients de là puisque je suis
en prison ben je fait imprimer tout ça
j'écris au juge des enfants j'ai créé au
procureur j'écris à la main de tant de
peine un nom sur ces deux ans de
produits sans j'ai fait un an ferme oui
donc pas cette année là les seuls
recours que j'avais c'était des
courriers vous avez peur tous les jours
de ce qui est arrivé vous disais c'est
une course contre la montre comment ils
vont la sortir de là elle était quand
même sous placement donc je connais un
peu confiance encore en la zone juge des
enfants ils vont faire quelque chose
rien fait pendant un an rien rien rien
pas une réponse en détention ne permet
même pas de porter plainte je ne suis
même pas visité par une brigade malgré
toutes les preuves que j'ai emmagasiné
donc oui oui on vous parlait d'emprise
et sousse garçons ils étaient menaçants
en disant voilà si tu me balance ou si
tu arrêtes de te prostituer va se passer
ça est-ce qu'il menaçait votre fils au
début non après moi quand je sors type
détention c'était le confinement le
premier confinement du coup je suis
monté à paris la charge en fait en
faisant passer pour un client je les
trouvais voilà bon bref je vais ramener
avec moi à toulouse et cette première
fois on a été ensemble ce faire elle
s'est fait expertiser a physiquement
donc il y avait elle avait des lésions
des ecchymoses une tuberculose latente
laver la galerie micro de l'ue pour la
sortir de là en fait donc vous arriver
c'est quelqu'un qui a un garçon qui a
été la chercher c'est un garçon qui a
fait le client et qui est ressorti de la
chambre avec elle d'accord et lui là et
il a rien vu le nom proxénète ce que
s'ils étaient dans la salle de bains
mais il a il n'a rien pu faire non il
faisait pas le poids ah ouais bah oui
c'est dire je la laissais il a été levée
la laisser partir et d'accord et après
de la envoyé un ami à vous fait passer
pour un client ouais c'est ça oui oui là
et qui lui a dit je viens de la part de
ta maman mais déjà en fait elle a voulu
partir elle voulait partir à ce moment
là elle était séquestrée si je puis dire
ce que ça faisait un moment que elle
voulait quitter les lieux mais qui la
laissait pas partir donc elle a saisi
cette occasion aussi mais vous étiez de
rentrer en contact avec elle avant de
elle savait qu'ils allaient venir on
s'était déjà parlé plusieurs fois voir
un message mais vous lui avez dit à
quelqu'un qui veut dire tune on savait
pas d'accord donc la personne arrive
dans la chambre et lui dit je suis bien
de la pac ta maman jeune ans il fait
mine de braquer un proxénète et de
partir avec elle en fait d'accord voilà
hockey est donc là elle se dit c'est
peut-être un nouveau cauchemar qui
commence est en fait c'est vrai la fin
d'un cauchemar exactement il ya là il
voulait à vouloir trouver oui elle est
dans un sale état entre 200 à semble
ensemble à toulouse et a fait ses
premières dépositions
pendant un mois et demi deux mois on a
franchement elle se reconstruit un petit
peu essoufflé 60 et enfin moi je croyais
qu'on avait vu le début du bout du
tunnel sur et en fin de compte je
n'avais pas anticipé que lui
mais il est revenu à la charge par les
réseaux sociaux il est rentré des
raumettes ouais il rendrait alors alors
un contact avec elle je vous avais fait
à ce moment là mais je me suis pas
aperçu de sa et l'emprise a repris
puisqu'elle m'a volé ma carte bleue et
qu'elle a fugué pour le rejoindre de
nouveau deuxième oui ça c'est incroyable
a voulu elle va le retrouver une
deuxième fois là vous vous apprenez
qu'elle est reparti alors que j'avais
déposé plainte et comment ça se fait
qu'il avait même pas été auditionnés ils
n'avaient même pas en deux mois il
n'avait même pas été auditionné en fait
il aurait été auditionné peut-être qu'il
serait pas revenu à la charge qu'est ce
qui se passe à syrte dans votre tête
qu'on vous dit j'ai envie de le
retrouver
alors que vous c'était pour moi un
cauchemar vous êtes sortez de là et vous
dit non je jeu il vous a encore retourné
le cerveau
c'est ça en fait l effet inscrivez des
éclats l'échangé vous étiez amoureuse
encore
donc
vous y retournez
la
france vont baisser les bras ce que vous
dites oui et non quand je me rends
compte qu'ils puissent assurer que vous
auriez pu baisser les bras vous dire
écoutez là je peux rien faire elle va y
retourner à chaque fois mais non là vous
faites moi tout le monde me dit baisser
les bras mais mon mari tout le monde a
vraiment tout le monde me dit de lâcher
la faire mais je peux pas du coup je
prends mon fils de 8 ans et je monte à
paris d'accord vous remontez à paris la
foule a retrouvé une nouvelle ère sur le
coup je la trouve pas en fait je sais à
peu près aux aînés mais j'arrive pas à
la trouver pour de vrai ça dure
maintenant c'est trop cher en plus à la
seule fois où il m'a écrit lui m'a écrit
en me disant que si j'ai retiré ma
plainte qui me rende ma fille donc je
vais dans les commissariats je leur
amène des captures d'écran il donne son
numéro de téléphone je ramène toutes mes
procédures ouais bon je pense passe rien
c'est pas bon et là vous là et là un
moment comment vous faites pour la
retrouver une nouvelle fois mais en fait
elle reste un tout petit peu en contact
avec son frère mais bien un tout petit
peu ça fait que je sais qu'elle va bien
fin qu'elle est vivante surtout en fin
de compte parce que je sais rien de plus
et
elle a plus confiance en moi parce que
je sais de l'éloigner de ce mec donc
pourrait sinon une autre beauté lui dit
faut pas que tu retournes avec ta mère
c'est plus les seuils de l'éloigner de
lui et puis je vous donne de
l'importance à lui en fait donc je la
ramène sans la ramenez moi même je passe
par quelqu'un en qui elle a confiance
qu'elle connaît puisqu'elle était
enceinte de quelques mois d'ailleurs
d'un prix d'une passe et je passe par
quelqu'un qui l'a fait revenir je la
fait revenir dans le sud en lui disant
je vais m'occuper de toi fin voilà c'est
le papa de nom donc côté un client sait
pas quand ces balcons de père inconnu
oui et puis à l'heure au dessin de l as
l'impression de redescendre par ses
propres moyens en fait puisque si elle
revient pas et qu'elle reste en fixe son
enfant sera placé à la naissance il ya
donc elle revient en fait sans que vous
interveniez c'est pas ma mère soit là où
c'est moi qui ai payé son billet tout
mais comme je suis pas d'accord elle a
l'impression que c'est vraiment elle est
en confiance on est donc là elle elle
revient aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez
un enfant donc de quel âge tiens moi dix
mois qui s'appelle comment kelvin
vous habitants sont maintenant oui donc
toute la famille toute la famille
aujourd'hui
le proxénète il en est où lieberman de
dépôt criminel en attente de vivement
depuis la loi de mars d'accord donc il a
été arrêté je croyais placé en détention
provisoire il sera jugé pour viol
séquestration violences prostitution
gravé et traite d'êtres humains la
traite d'êtres humains pour l'instant
elle ne figure pas sur les chefs
d'inculpation mais vu tout ce qu'elle a
vécu j'espère même que mon avocat
arrivera élevé il a quel âge lui l'a 20
ans
aujourd'hui ça y est c'est de passer à
autre chose
n'est plus du tout je vous en prie enfin
un nouveau petit ami
ça se passe bien
ça arrivait à être heureuse à nouveau
avec le petit aussi avec le petit
c'est incroyable votre histoire